أنت تعرف أن الناس قد يتساءلون كيف يمكنك أن
تصبح شيفًا ملكيًا ، وبينما كنت أتعمق
في قصتك ، علمت أنك
ببساطة كتبت رسالة تقول إنك تريد
أن تكون ملكة الطهاة ، فأرسلت تلك
الرسالة إلى قصر باكنغهام فور
حصولك على الوظيفة.  يعني ما يخبرنا المزيد
عن كيف حدث ذلك
كنت أنام على ميل أشاهد
حفل الزفاف الملكي مع عائلتي آه الأمير
تشارلز في ذلك الوقت الليدي ديانا
سبنسر واه ظننت أنني أريد أن أكون
طاهًا ملكيًا في Royal Kitchen لذلك عندما كنت
وصلت إلى المنزل ، لقد كتبت رسالة إلى الملكة
لم أفكر مطلقًا في أنني أسمع أي شيء مرة أخرى
بعد فترة ليست طويلة من إجراء مقابلة في
القصر ، ثم كنت أعمل
في المطابخ ، وكان أمرًا لا يصدق ،
كان كل شيء توقعته أن يكون شيئًا واحدًا.
لم أكن أتوقع أنني سأقوم
بالفعل بتقشير الجزر من أجل
حصان الملكة وأقوم بتقطيع طعام الكلاب من
أجل فصيلة الكورجيس الملكية في الوقت الذي
يكون فيه الكلب البري
كل يوم ، عليك اتباع قائمة
كبد لحم البقر والدجاج على شكل أرنب
لأنهم  إعادة الأشياء الأكثر أهمية هو
ضغط أكبر بكثير من القيام بمأدبة رسمية في
الواقع ، أنت تعرف حقًا أنني يجب أن
أقول إنني لست متفاجئًا ، أراهن أن الملكة
أم كانت تركز أكثر على طعام
حيواناتها لأنها كانت تحب حيواناتها
كثيرًا من الطعام من أجل  هي نفسها كما لو كانت
تبدو كما لو كنت تعلم لأنني كنت
أقرأ أنك قلت إنها
أكلت حقًا لتعيش ولا تعيش لتأكل ، أعني أنها
لم تكن من عشاق الطعام ،
هذا صحيح ، لم تكن من عشاق الطعام ، كما
تعلمون ، كان الأمر صعبًا  للحصول على أطباق جديدة
في القائمة ، لقد أحببت نفس الأطباق القديمة
المفضلة ،
إذا كان علينا إرسال طبق جديد أو
فكرة جديدة ، فقد احتجنا إلى إرسال الوصفة
أيضًا وفي مقطع الفيديو الخاص بي على YouTube أشارك
قصة عمل طبق فراولة  لقد
صنعت للملكة ونسيت
إرسال الوصفة ، وكانت هناك ملاحظة
عادت في الكتاب تقول من هم
بنات المزارع المحجبات أو من هم بنات المزارع المحجبات ،
لقد أرسلت الوصفة مباشرة مرة أخرى
مع المساعد الذي كان خطأ كبير
نحن حقًا  رأيتها في المطبخ
لم تأت  في كثير من الأحيان ولكني
أتذكر ذات مرة في ساندرينجهام
أنها دخلت المطبخ وكنت أقوم بصنع
الكريب وكان لدي ستة أرطال على
الموقد وكنت أقلبهم
بملعقة وأتت الملكة
ووقفت تراقبني.  لن أقول أي شيء
ثم فجأة قالت ليس هذا
الغش
قالت ألا يجب أن تقلبهم
، ظننت يا إلهي أه
أداء القيادة الملكية هنا ، لذا فعلت واحدًا
تلو الآخر جميعهم الستة وهي
آخر برافو ثم ضحكت
وابتعدوا عن الضغط الحقيقي
الأجنبي